for a woman to find a guy who's truly on  a level who truly treats her the way she  should be treated that's once every  couple years if that you ain't just  gonna go out there [ __ ] a new dude  every week and say yeah he's worth [ __ ]  yeah he treats me good enough to get my  [ __ ] and you know what's funny about  the universe it's actually beautiful  about the universe because it's equal  and opposite forces when you devour  yourself it's kind of like men can smell  it on you they can just look at a [ __ ]  no oh and that's the way it works so you  have to be very careful as a female and  sit and go does this man truly deserve  to [ __ ] me if you think about it the  answer 99 of the time especially if  you're promiscuous is no so when a woman  is sleeping around with all these men  she's devouring herself she's devaluing  herself and the world knows God knows  the universe knows when a man does it he  doesn't devalue himself at all that's  just the way it works